bu Eyvah siyo doğuruyor nasıl geliyor
kulağa bilmiyorum ama Eyvah siyo
doğruyor diye bir kitap yazdım ve
siyonun doğurma Fikri herkesin o kadar
ilgisini çekti ki herkes kitabın başlığı
okuyunca teknoloji marifetiyle bir
erkeğin doğum yapma hikayesini anlattığı
hayal ettim siyonun kadın olma
olasılığını dair düşünmedik olmuş benim
için iyi oldu çünkü bu merak kitabı 3
baskı yaptırdık çok sattı çok okundu ne
mutlu bana Küçük Kadınlar romanı oku
yanlarımız vardır Ata geçen sene yeni
filminde çekildi kitabın yazarı ve
dünyanın kalbini beğenisini kazanan bu
izame yakıt 1860'lı yıllarda
bu croman yazan muviza meal kıt
Romanların satılması için uzun bir süre
Amber diye bir isim kullandı bu Takma
adın yazarın erkek mi kadın mı olduğunun
anlaşılmasına ve bu anlamda da romanın
pozitif etkisi ne başarı olarak geri
dönüş sağladığına inanılıyor başka bir
örnek Avustralya'da yazar Pamela
lindfors Emin hiçbiriniz için hiçbir şey
ifade etmiyor ama aslında beyazperdeye
uyarlanan efsane Mary poppins kitabının
yazarı Onun da ismine iyi el çağırsa
olarak salmışlar ve gene kadın ve erkek
mi olduğunun anlaşılmasını istemiş
Yayıncılık 9.30 yıllardan bahsediyoruz
okulda Okuduğunuz Jenner kitabının
yazarı Charles Don't Cha top de yaklaşık
180 yıl önce kitabı basılırken kitabın
üzerine charlott monte ismini değil
çorba al ismini yazı
bu istemiş iki kardeşi var emri ve en
İkisi de yazar Emir ve en de yazdıkları
kitapta Charlotte Don't eden ilham
alarak Alice ve Akın bal isminin
yazılmasını istemişler bir erkek yazarın
kitap basmasının daha büyük başarı
sağlayacağına inanılmış 3 kısık kardeşin
yazar olarak başarı sağlayacağı
öngörülmediği düşünmediği için benzer
örnekleri artırmak mümkün Hatta bazıları
diyecek ki ya bunlar çok uzaklarda kaldı
artık dünya değişti keşke öyle olsa
keşke sizin düşündüğünüz gibi bir dünya
olsa Ama daha yakınlara gelelim 1990'lı
yıllarda eminim çoğunuzun okuduğu Belki
de izlediği Harry Potter serisi ne kadar
meşhur oldu ne kadar büyük sükse yaptı
değil mi mi Harry Potter serisinin
yazarı bı doğal cepli trolling ama biz
onu j k
bu video tanıdık joanne caitlyn
isimlerini hiçbir yerde kullanmadığı
kadın ve erkek olduğu belli olmadı Çünkü
yayıncısına ilk Harry Potter romanıyla
gittiğinde yayıncı bir kadın yazardım
yazdığı romanı erkek çocuklar okumaz
dedi onu onun üzerine ismini değiştirmek
ve sadece isminin baş harfleriyle
soyadını kullanmak durumunda kaldı çok
uzak değil 90'lı Yıllar barn eden
kadından yazar olmaz kadın dans iyi
olduğunu düşünülemeyeceği gibi kadının
yazar olduğunda düşünemiyor bir hikaye
anlatacağım şimdi gözlerinizi Kapatın
bir Anaokulu hayal edin altı yaşında bir
kız çocuğu hiçbir derse ilgisi yok hemen
Hemen hiçbir dersen keyif alıyor bir
tanesi hariç resim ders ne zamanki resim
dersi var boyaları çıkartıyor büyük bir
şevkle harika renkli resimler yapıyor
gene böyle bir ders öğretmen sıraları
dolaşıyor
bu sıradan arasında kızın başına doğru
gidiyor herhalde Kağıt üzerindeki
renklerden bir anlar çıkaramadığı için
ne resmi yapıyorsun diye Kıza soruyor Bu
kız kafasını bile kaldırmadan an çok da
düşünmeden tanrının resmi yapıyorum
diyor Öğretmen hafif müstesi ağrının
neye benzediğini kimse bilmiyor ki
Yiyecek oluyor kız gene kafasını
kaldırmadan iki dakika bekle bütün dünya
öğrenecek diyor Tarık'ın resmini yapmak
ne kadar cüretkâr bir şey değil mi hayal
etmek tanrının neye benzediğini hayal
etmek Google'ın iki kurucusundan bir
tanesi leri patch leri peşin çok
sevdiğim bir sözü var yok ki Büyük
Hayaller kurun çılgın Hayaller kurun
inanın Dünyada çılgın sayısı az orada
rekabet dazo az rekabetin olduğu yerde
kendinizi gösterin korktuğunuz da
endişeler sen izden
o kadar iyi hazırlanır sanız hazırlanın
hayatınızda Başka Hayal kırıklıkları
olacak engellerle karşı
karşılaşacaksınız ve Biraz önce
söylediğim gibi kadından olmaz kadından
olmaz kadın yapamaz çok fazla
duyacaksınız önemli olan o yaşanılan
Hayal kırıklıklarından öğrenmeye
çalışmak ayağa kalkıp yürümeye devam
etmek keke Eyvah siyo doğuruyor kitaba
ismini veren bu yaşanmış hikaye 2012
yılında Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'nde
geçiyor Bir hala ismi bilinen Yavuz
şirketi yeni bir üst düzey yönetici bir
sivri ataması yapıyor ve bunun içinde
Google'dan çok büyük bir transferle
marisam ayrı davet ediyorlar Manisa
Mahir daha 37 yaşında o zaman
Amerika'daki en büyük şirketler yer
aldığı Ford'un endeksindeki 500 şirket
var içindeki 7 kadın sil
iyi düşün 500 tane şirketin içinde
sadece yedi tane kadın seviyorlar Baran
gençler oluyor 37 yaşında dev Ya bunun
başına geçtiği için ve Google'dan yanına
geçerken de ilk çocuğuna hamile ya buna
rağmen onu davet ediyor ve bu en büyük
görevi ona veriyor Aradan birkaç sene
geçiyor varis ama Hayır Tekrar hamile
kalıyor ve bu sefer ikiz bebekleri
doğurmak üzere birkaç ay görevini
bırakma kararını Açıklıyor İşte o karar
açıklanınca yer yerinden oynuyor
Amerika'daki regülatör denetim kuruluşu
dahil herkes acaba siyo görevden ayrılıp
doğuma gittiğindeki şirket performansı
şirket hisselerinin değeri kötü
etkilenir miyiz sorgulamaya başlıyor
yani Eyvah siyo doğruyor diye herkes
konuşmaya başlıyor bu şey biliyor
musunuz siyonun bir kadının
12'de hayatı boyunca en mutlu olacağı an
zehir oluyor çünkü herkes Eyvah siyo
doğruyor diyor Eyvah suyu doğuruyor
deyince ki Manisa Mahir doğuma gidiyor
geri geliyor ve hissede şirkette de
hiçbir şey olmuyor varis ama hayır hayır
hala Başarılı bir şekilde Görevine devam
ediyor Ben bunu öğrenince Acaba dedim
bugüne kadar o Amerikan en büyük
şirketlerin içinde hiç başka anne baba
olan siyah olmamış mı onlarca yüzlerce
var Baba olan an ama anne olan o kadar
az ki Niye Çünkü dedim ya 500 şirket
içinde sadece yedi tane kadın seviyor bu
tarz iyi olarak doğuranların sayısı o
kadar artık işte onun için Eyvah Ziyo
doğruyu diyor herkesi yok çocuk
doğurmaya karar verince daha da komiğini
söyleyeyim size Amerika'daki Force
şirketleri
2'si olan ve ism-i Joker olanların
sayısı kadınsı yollardan daha fazla
Amerika'da ismi zor olan cumhuriyetçi
senatörler in sayısı kadın senatörler
den daha fazla kendimizi utandı payını
araştırmayı Türkiye'de yapmadım ama
yapmış olsam emin olun Türkiye'de Murat
ya da Mehmet isimli siyahların sayısı
kadın siyahlardan daha fazla çıkacaktı
bu Eyvah Ziyo doğruyor orta biçimde
değil mi biçimi yok 2 milyon yıllık
insanlık tarihinde vücudumuzun
üzerindeki en az gelişen organ beyin 2
milyon yıl önce hangi reflekstir
veriyorsa hangi büyüklükte hangi
performansta ise hemen hemen şu anda da
aynısından da Hiçbir gelişme göstermemiş
ve Beynimiz bize gerçekleri ya da mutlak
doğru değil Çoğu zaman görmek istedik
bu gösteriyor Sonuç olarak da düşünmeden
bakın burası çok önemli Altını çiziyorum
düşünmeden beynimizin sözünü dinleyerek
bilinçsiz önün yargıları bizi
yönetmesine izin veriyoruz asıl İronik
olan ise ilk hayatında başarımız doğru
kararlar verebilme yeteneğinize bağlı
iken biz bu karar verme sürecini sadece
önyargılarımız ile yönlendiriyoruz ve o
önyargılar da 2 milyon yıldır hiç
gelişmeyen bir organ tarafından
yönetiliyor bu hepimizin dna'sında
dokusunda da işte o fabrika ayarlarıyla
gelen kadından yönetici olmaz kadından
iş insanı olmaz kadından sporcu olmaz
kadında sanatçı olmaz kadın yazar olmaz
kadın ağır kaldıramaz kadın geç
çalışamaz paten akşam yemeğe çıkamaz
gibi önyargılar var bir de bunu üzere
bu dokuyla gelen DNA ile gelen
önyargıların dışında 0-6 yaş içinde aile
ortamında annemizden babamızdan
etrafınızdaki kardeşlerden ve aile
büyüklerinden gördüklerimiz var Onların
birbirine davranışları onların birbirine
İddaa şekilleri de bizim 9'u üzerine
işliyor borsa sanıyorum daha fazlasına
ihtiyaç yok bu örneklerin hepsi o
bilinçsiz önyargıların sonucunda
bilinçsiz önyargıları değiştirmek için
de aslında başlangıç noktası dilimizi
değiştirmeye başladı çalışmak ilköğreti
ise Bugün sizinle paylaşmak istediğim
önemli kısım ise her ne kadar şu ana
kadar paylaştıkların çoğunu kadınların
üzerine odaklandığı ise bu konu bir
erkek konusu arkadaşlar bu konu Bir
Erkek Meselesi Çünkü erkeklerin
bilinçsiz ön yargılarını değiştirmek
zorundayız erkekler hala
Allah katında Hatta hayatın birçok karar
verme noktasında ve o koltuklarda doğru
kararları vermeye onları Bizim eve
gitmemiz onlara doğruyu öğretmemiz lazım
erkeklerin bilinçsiz on yargıları
değiştirmek zorundayız Zira erkekler
zaman zaman en yakınlarında en çok
sevdiklerini iddia ettikleri kadınlara
dair şiddet uygulayan biliyorlar Hatta
onları öldürebiliyor lareau bilinçsiz
önyargılar nedeniyle erkeklerin
değişmesi lazım işte bu yüzden yaklaşık
iki sene önce 2018 yılının Mayıs ayında
toplumun içinde farklı alanlarda ilham
veren XL erkek bir araya geldik ve
toplumsal cinsiyet eşitliğinin
sağlanmasına amaçlayan Türkiye'de ilk
dünyada ikinci kadın konusunu Erkek
Meselesi olarak gören bir sivil toplum
kuruluşunu kurduk a
bu yanındayız Derneği ile birlikte
erkeklere Hedef almak farkındalıklarını
arttırmak şiddeti sonlandırmaya ve
erkeklerin eğitim mesine yönelik
çalışmalar yapmak bak kadın istihdamını
arttırmak ev emeğin de ev işlerinde
ortaklığı sağlamak erkeklerin kadınlara
evde yardım etmesi değil evdeki işi
erkek ve kadının paylaşmasını sağlamak
eğitimde fırsat eşitliğini sağlamak yani
o toplumsal cinsiyet eşitliğini sağlayan
4 boyutta sağlıkta içinde iş hayatında
Siyasette fırsat ve hak eşitliğini
sağlayabilmek erkek dilini ve Daha
önemlisi de erkek zihnini erkeklerin
bilinçsiz önyargılarını erkeklerin yoğun
olduğu ortamlarda stadyumlarda kahvede
berber dükkanında kışlada camide
değiştirme çabası içinde olmak işte
yanına
Ya bırak XL erkek bu konuyu kendimize
mesele ettik vazife edindik ha ben
sizlerin Ben kendimin Ben hepimizin
Hayal etmeye devam etmesini istiyorum o
altı yaşındaki kız çocuğu gibi ben
siyahların doğuracağı Bir Dünya hayal
ediyorum ben daha çok kadın siyah hayal
ediyorum ben kadınların erkeklerin sahip
olduğu haklara ve fırsatlara
ulaşabilmesi ne Onların da aynı haklı
fırsatlara sahip olmasını istiyorum bu
değişim yaratmak hepimizin görevi
Birleşmiş Milletler'in cinsiyet eşitliği
ve kadın konusundaki önemli
sebeplerinden biriside Tea for shibui
seçin kamuoyu yüzü bizlerin çok çok iyi
tanıdığı aktris Emma Watson hem baktın
genellikle konuşmalarına şu basit
sorularla başlıyor sana
Evet şimdi toplumsal cinsiyet eşitliği
konusundaki hassasiyetinin arkasında
benzer sorular var hem de Vakfı'nın iki
sorusu şu bugün değilse ne zaman ben
değilsem kim Ben her sabah kalktığımda
bu iki soruyu dilimde e Kendime
soruyorum bugün değilse ne zaman ben
değilsem kim Siz değilseniz Kim kim ben
değilsem Kim o